good evening ladies and gentlemen
meeting Development Committee of the
14th of
where are we December
so this is emergency evacuation
announcement there are no planned fire
drills no no no right so if the alarm
goes off please leave the building in an
orderly fashion through the nearest fire
exits because those stores there and I
think that one now you can get out of
please yep the fire 70 point is in the
island in front of the main entrance to
the building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff please note that the
meeting will be audio recorded please
switch off mobile phones or turn them
onto silent please note that toilets and
hand washing facilities are in the foyer
area
members there's a neat and used
microphones
during the meeting when I invite you to
speak please wait until there is a
microphone in front of you before
speaking as microphones are needed for
the hearing Loop and for the audio
recording these are all switched on and
ready for you to speak so you don't need
to adjust them
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in life of the Constitution I will
ask for a show of hands four and then
against recommendations and we'll also
ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
foreign
that's basically it yep and if you want
to speak on anything just give me a
passion
all right then
the time is 7 30. so
right then agenda items one on two
apologies for absencies we've gone
apologies for absence
councilor butcher Council the shore
councilor Foster
and councilor Milne uh Council Hoy will
be substituting for councilor Tracy
Knight and councilor Elaine Gadsden will
be substituting for counselor sure
man attending mem
ster Stanley uh what's Jack Lawman
supposed to be here or not
last night he didn't make the committee
so I don't know if he if he was standing
in for someone would you think you'll
find it I think you'll find that his
name is on the committee yeah
from from the
well he's he's not here so unless the
door's opening is he coming in now
that's Adrian no so he's not here so
he's not here he's not here put him down
his mission then put him down is missing
thank you okay that's fine
uh non-members attending we have none
uh I'd send you an item four minutes of
the meeting held on 22nd of November
of the minutes agreed members
agree cool I'll sign those
let's do this a bit later
right
any are there any Declarations of
Interest members
councilor Williams
chairman um yeah I
a matter of interest on item six and
seven non-portunity interest is my
grandson works for ipico
okay agenda item six airport Business
Park South in Cherry Orchard Way
Rochford please note that this
application has been withdrawn by the
applicant and will therefore not be
considered at this meeting for the
development committee
so they move on to agenda item seven
which is airport Business Park South
Venturi Orchard Way watchford
Mike's strengths will present the
officer's report ready to go Mike thank
you chairman
um this application site is part of the
airport business park that's sort of
this area here Cherry Orchard Way to the
left of your screen and the roundabout
entering the site Costa The Hub and then
the estate road that you see runs around
the middle it's all complete this part
is under construction and ipco's
existing building they're your
applicants tonight is up and running
here we're looking at this area of land
here right next door to it it's a site
of about 2.4 hectares of vacant land
and to the north of that just for your
bearings is the new location of the West
Westcliff Rugby Club
if we could see the problem thank you
Yvonne here we see the application in
better detail on the site the proposed
building sort of broadly Square in form
a very similar design to the one next
door because they're all part of the
same family
you'll see the car park links with the
existing building because these are the
same occupiers and the concept here is
that it centralizes ipco between the two
buildings in a Consolidated operation
the blue areas that you see here are the
circulation roads round to the service
yards which actually connect between the
two buildings for lorries and the like
and the car parking areas here they've
probably shared and allow some over
spill there's a realignment here that
the spine that goes through the
landscape spine that goes through the
estate as a
results of revised design between the
plots there's been some variation here
some sort of narrowing but taking it up
to that point that was previously agreed
the general alignment but there's a
slight change to the shape to bring the
service road in that's also in this
application
if we could see the elevations please
Yvonne thanks as you see members
familiar with the existing building it's
clad in
sheet profiling and you'll see the roof
design is like this sort of barreled
spans that run across on the end
elevation there some figures for it it's
about 11 270 square meters in Gross
floor space
there is an overall length of 116.8
meters width of 82.6 and the ridge
height is 9.6 meters but the height to
Walling that you see it's a fairly
shallow roof is 8.1 meters
the coloring of the building the walls
would be in what they call Alaska mid
gray type color the the appearance of
this building is various Shades of Gray
so the Alaska is a mid-gray color with
the framing around the windows and the
detailing the building in the dark what
they refer to as anthracite color which
is a deeper gray and the roof would be
finished in a albatross color was the
name of it which is a lighter gray or
some would say a hazy blue
the I've mentioned the realignment there
is if we could jump back to the site
plan please uh Yvonne thank you you're
seeing the report there's mention of a
fence which is is set back into the site
and around the top because these
applicants deal with
[Music]
um
uh air air travel
Aviation there's a need for this site to
be secure to prevent
um terrorists that sort of thing so what
they've done they've set it back in the
public Frontage and the Landscaping that
they're proposing will soften that
impact I think we have a detail of that
if we can please Yvonne you'll see that
it's the kind of mesh fence where they
vary the the pattern like it's like a
Tartan type finish to it it's a lot more
decorative than your Palisades and
things like that and it goes well with
the Landscaping when that establishes
there's a there's one up the center of
Victoria Avenue I think in south end if
you notice it amongst the trees there
the
proposed building generally Accords with
the requirements of the [ __ ] you can jump
to the location plan again if sorry the
block plan if you like you've got
um that's your joint policy that was
prepared between South End and the
Rochford District that was for the
airport environment to bring to this
area
Industrial Development that particularly
is involved in high skills we've got a
lot of development like mots and
servicing and other the intention was to
develop the skills base and because ipco
are now centralized on this they're
bringing to this site the hope of 498
full-time jobs of which
268 would be new jobs so they're
relocating 230 jobs from the premises
they've got scattered about and locating
here but the Fulfillment of this scheme
would create an extra 260 jobs in their
estimation
members will see from the report
that
despite the merits of the application
officers are concerned about the
strength of the Landscaping in this
vicinity and there's a condition nine in
the recommendation that would ask for
extra tree planting to beef that up and
to give you a a tree-lined street or
effect of that which is in accord with a
national planning policy guidance that
we have at the moment to enhance that
um
The Proposal is of good design and
generally Accords with the principles
and Ambitions of the business park and
you'll see that officers are
recommending approval now on the
addendum
members will have seen that from
paragraph 350 on page 720 of the officer
report there is actually an outstanding
consultation with the county council's
sustainable drainage team
you can't see it on this plan but the uh
broad outline of these sites includes
this landscape strip that's got swiles
and holding ponds Etc as well as a
broader strategy for holding tanks under
car parking errors to hold the Surplus
rainfall and then discharge it at an
acceptable rate now whilst that strategy
is part of the outline and a lot of it
has already been implemented on the
broader site officers would still prefer
to have the comfort of a reply from the
county team that the flooding
information put in with this application
is effectively agreed by by the experts
and we had hoped to be in a position to
bring that to you
so whilst the expectation of District
officers is that the application
drainage details will fit within the
wider site drainage we nevertheless
require the consideration and the reply
of the specialist body
now on the basis that as a result of
this debate tonight
members have no other concerns to raise
then there's a revised recommendation
that officers would like to put before
you that the members delegate the
application to the council's director of
place to determine on the basis of the
office of recommendation you have set
out on page 7.1 but to take account of
the reply to consultation when received
from the leak lead local flood Authority
the county Suds team this will enable a
timely decision not to be issued on the
application because this is subject to
what we call a planning performance
agreement and ensure the Swift Delivery
of economic growth so that's the revised
recommendation chairman thank you thank
you
foreign
if you'd like to uh
invite you to uh the allocation just the
committee
uh he you know five minutes and we'll
let you know when there's a minute left
to go
thank you chair uh my name is Nick
Diamond I'm Henry boots planning agent
we welcome you officers positive
recommendation which is the result of
extensive pre and post application
discussions ipico are as you're aware a
world leader in the manufacturing of
Aviation seating and a long-time
employer in the district
they currently occupy units on Aviation
way and as displayed on the screen there
plot 7 to the south of the existing
proposal on the business park
this proposal responds to their
accommodation and security requirements
and will allow the consolidation onto
one site through the delivery of a
purpose-built unit
as it's been pointed out in addition to
accommodating the relocation of the
existing jobs the building has also been
designed so that it can accommodate far
higher numbers
of jobs
in addition to a consistent approach to
design and Landscaping The Proposal will
also be of a similar mass into ipico one
The Proposal incorporates a pedestrian
link between the two buildings and
provides for 249 car parking spaces
which include 12 blue badge 10 active
charging Bays 12 passive provision and
70 cycle spaces
hgvs have their own segregated access
and the service yard can be accessed as
being shown from both parts of the
building thereby adding to efficiencies
The Proposal Accords with the
aspirations of your joint area action
plan and the mppf and will further
complement the Park's offer facilitate
the consolidation of a long-standing
employer of the district and in so doing
deliver economic benefits at a time of
economic uncertainty
I would respectfully ask that you follow
your officer's recommendation and
approve this application thank you
thank you
all right we have one ward council here
tonight which is Council Williams
Council Williams you'd like to address
the
committee now would you like to take
part in a debate no I have nothing at
this moment thank you thank you I need
so if you mind
members that we would like to give you a
chance to speak and I think councilor
Stanley had his hand up first
thank you chairman
um two things although the we're waiting
for the suds to bring their evidence
forward
this is a real major site which is going
to have
well the drainage on that site was the
land itself so there is going to be
quite an excessive amount of water
coming from this building and
surrounding areas as it's going to be
concreted
the other the one thing that video want
to ask is lighting
um the lighting of the area is that
going to be from Posts uh lamp standards
or is the lighting going to be
surrounding of the building and enclosed
to the building in other words not
all areas sort of thing
um that's one of my points
the other point is that
in the top right hand corner that we're
looking at at the moment is that for any
particular amenity is that for parking
or what is that for example a service
yard sorry do you mean the service yard
because what okay
yeah
yeah
um just thinking of amenity space for
the occupants when they have their lunch
or something like that I haven't heard
anything in the way of uh resting rest
area or anything like that and the other
thing is
um
with the parking of the vehicles I
noticed that there is only 12 uh
um recharging uh places but
on the basis that we are moving into
electric cars
is it considered that there may be more
parties not even 10 so is there maybe
more areas for
carb for charging of vehicles as there
are 490 places and only 12 places for
charging a vehicle it would seem so that
would be a bit ridiculous when you've
got
quite a number of vehicles that will be
electric and it's not consistent I don't
think it is anyway okay that's it thank
you I'll put those five questions to
accounts um Mike so we've got Lighting
in the area do you want to go over the
flooding again which is no I think uh I
think the uh yeah I think Suds will will
sort that out because you can't very
well use the ponds that are there
already because they're they're already
allocated to those those places and I
don't see anywhere where you can put
ponds other than in that far corner so
yeah sorry about service charge amenity
and the electric cars charging points I
would like to comment on the flooding
question actually chairman let's leave
that one to last
um
looking at the lighting you'll see it
condition six of the officer
recommendation that other than the sort
of one meter high Bollard type
we're saying that if they wish to put it
on higher columns or possibly mounts on
the building we're requesting details of
that okay so we would expect the
applicants to bring that back to us
and similarly uh
for
um the vehicle charging you'll see
actually the next condition condition
seven we're asking for details of the
electric vehicle charging I would caveat
that that it crosses over into building
regulations and obviously if an
applicant finds on a planning permission
it's required to do one thing but then
do something else on building rigs the
government does say we shouldn't meddle
with somebody else's legislation but I
understand the sentiment it was been in
planning or been suggested in planning
because we're looking for sustainability
and no doubt the applicants will want to
provide the opportunity for their staff
and visitors to recharge as as part of
you know the general plan
um but I think we'll wait and see what
the applicant is prepared to provide by
way of discharging the the condition so
that's lighting and the
um electric cars now with the breakout
space
there's some provision in the layout
internally in the floor space to the
building I get it that what you're
saying about outside areas given the
summer we've just had
but there's there's uh an arrangement
inside the building like a bit like some
of the ideas we had for our own new
offices but outside in these Landscaping
areas in these areas here
um there'd be provision for seating and
discrete little places Etc so there is
some opportunity and then across the
road I don't know if you can zoom out a
bit um Yvonne which will actually help
me with the final point in flooding as
well
this area here would be public
so his little doubt there'd be litter
bins and I'm not sure what the orange
flashes are but I'd suggest they're
possibly seats or or lunar bins of some
sort so the public would be able to move
through there as a recreational space if
they want to go for a 20-minute walk
that's and that's accessible to all the
occupiers okay so that the concept of
the estate would be that they have this
green spine through which they can move
and if they want to go and you know
refresh for 20 minutes recover or
something like that they'd have access
to that space so they don't need to be
providing spaces on each individual plot
on this development okay but there are
some within as well so they've got the
best of of Both Worlds I would say
um if I just answer on the flooding
there is no swales on this particular
site but unlike some of the housing
schemes we get when members will be
aware that each scheme has to
substantiate itself what you're actually
dealing with is one plot on a wide
escape and I think I said in my
presentation that although
there are specific
engineering to do with this site that
we're waiting on a view from floods if
you like it plugs in
to the strategy that's on the whole site
which includes further along here off
this I haven't got a shot of it but
there are swales parked here and they've
done it when they've got outline consent
and all the flood risk assessment to do
with that they've done a massive
calculation of what they would need in
all the engineering and a lot of the uh
sort of main provision is in because
you've got units in it and then there's
the the necessaries just to do with this
scheme that they have to finalize with
this planning application so there is
swales further along it's unfortunate I
can't I can't show you them okay now
there would have been a calculation done
at outline stage of what they anticipate
would be the size of the buildings
so it's already provided for in the
network if you like in the swales but if
let's say they made this building in
detail 10 bigger then the flood risk
assessment has got to try and
accommodate that extra enlargement or it
may be made up if a development on
another site is perhaps smaller so
they're trying to achieve a degree of
fit in flooding for this detail plot
in association with the wider strategy
as a whole hopefully that that gives
members the comfort that I think they're
looking for and just just um just one
thing chairman
I wouldn't have thought that the
rest area that you're talking about will
be an exactly a good place when you've
got lorries coming in and out and Carl's
coming in and out with
um
fumes and and uh micro micro particles
while you're having your sandwiches and
a cup of tea I would have thought it
would have been better if if you don't
mind that it would have been better to
move it away from the traffic so that
you could sit peacefully there rather
than have traffic passing you sometimes
it's not always a good idea hey whatever
the case does okay looking at the plan
counselor Stanley where the seating main
scene outside is is by the electric
points so forth just here and there's
another area just so I'm trying not to
blindfill another area just here that's
got seat outside seating as well yeah so
they're with actually within the site
okay any new questions members
Castle leaves thank you a couple of
things um if I could just have a bit of
clarification
um uh on the recommendation
recommendation 16 the metal gate to
allow access to Residents uh the site is
that the existing metal gates that
restrict access to the circle route
um the the main road around the site or
is that something new because it's not
really
it's not indicated on the drawings that
I could see
um and it seems to be uh
uh a question that I've asked in the
past about whether there was planning
permission needed for the gates that
have actually been put up to stop the
boy races effectively around the uh the
site the substantial great Gates
um the the plan is to actually use those
to shut the site down the whole site
down during out of hours okay and what I
understood secondly
the s106 agreement monies are going this
I'd like a bit of clarification on that
obviously I can see the travel
information pack
um but for a
development of this size that does seem
quite light
I wonder if you could just uh clarify
that for us sorry chairman I was being
whispered to in here I didn't get the
second point about the monies and the
106.6 agreement you've got the
um
item 13 on the recommendation uh
includes a travel pack a travel
information pack but the size of
development that seems quite light
chairman
um I'm confused because there was
reference to item 16 and the conditions
there was only 14 and I can't see if the
member could be more specific at what
page five of the of the
that they tested at the bottom of the
page there should be an item number so
like seven and then point five is the
page no no no no sorry this is
um item seven make sure you've got the
right item
yeah
I'm thinking we're talking about the
withdrawn item because that's uh I did
see a travel pack in there actually yep
okay yeah there very sorry I do
apologize
um on the actually is a relevant uh
question uh regarding s106 monies though
um could you explain what uh what s106
monies have been allocated for this
particular project not I don't believe
there's a section 106 agreement in this
particular application what members
although it's a standalone full
application in its own right there is a
pair and outline permission
so the developers are developing the
site comprehensively I think Henry boot
developments the applicants but ipco are
developing this particular plot
now there's although it's a standalone
it's not Reserve matters pursuant to the
outline so it's not jigsawed in with
with the outline permission
the commitments on the outline still
stand
now unfortunately I can't help members
I'm not familiar with the outline
consent so I couldn't explain to you
what money is but I believe from what
I've heard in the office you can shut
your eyes but you can't shut your ears
to conversations that are being had that
there was a commitment to a bus
uh subsidy so that was one of the ones
that was mentioned I can't remember the
amount but the idea was that this site
and the Beltway site for the housing
around the corner would subsidize a bus
route
yeah um now if that's in the outline
permission given that a lot of the other
units are all being done under the
outline that would still come forward
but as this is a standalone item on this
unit there is nothing in the
recommendation either been suggested by
County highways or by officers to
contribute to anything financially
there's no section 106 requirement on
this particular application can I just
instruct there Mike
um 7.22 there is actually mention of a
travel plan but by the top 3.57 which
basically says uh travel plans declined
in the 2021 in ppf and it seems to be a
long-term management strategy for the
organization of
of site that seeks to live a sustainable
transport objectives
what with page numbers 7.22 722 is the
page number yeah and it's 3.57
which I've just read out the main bit
there
gonna put in
that chairman isn't any money is it's
just giving a yeah
um if I can explain when you operate a
commercial site in order for the
interest to sustainability a big
operator in particular can encourage
staff to say car share or make cycle
provision and things like this so they
have a travel plan as an organization
where when people are recruited they say
oh how about car sharing where do you
live there's a group that come from Lee
a group that come from Basildon here's
the lead contact or something like that
and so that's what they mean by a travel
plan that that doesn't require
a section 106 agreement the section 106
is a sort of enforced in the courts
where there's a mitigation perhaps like
you were saying about
an essential need to finance the bus
route to get it pumped so that in the
first few years it operates and then
people start using it as the money that
the planning application provides
depletes so it's justifiable to to do
that which is I think has been done in
the outline but it's not part of this
it's unnecessary which I think is why
the officer hasn't included it does that
help Council leaves yeah that's that's
very clear thank you like the gate now
isn't it yeah the the
um uh concern I had I did raise this
when we had the update on the [ __ ] site
that there are two gates that are put
around the site
um that I wasn't sure whether they
actually needed planning permission and
um the people who were doing the
presentation were going to come back to
us right to clarify the situation
because I've heard nothing since so for
nature I've seen those Gates this
application doesn't include there is a
gate there somewhere in that vicinity to
protect their own service yard on their
side but I think you're talking of gates
that are further back near Costa I am
yeah and I think the point about Joy
Riders and things I mean when I went on
one of my site visits on there one that
was closed and I depart the other side
of it and walked around
because they're more than uh two meters
higher they need planning permission
okay and I'm not aware if planning
permission has been sought
it's sometimes the case that whilst
they've got plant and things on on a
site expensive diggers you know you pay
hundreds of thousands of pounds for them
things that they rep these kind of
things just to help their own security
and then when the development is built
out and fulfilled sometimes they're
removed but I I can't help you with any
knowledge that they're meant to be
they're permanent or whatever but if
they were to have permanence I would say
they would need planning permission yes
so this is not part of no no it's an
application
outside the meeting there is a similar
guide to protect their own service yard
somewhere about there just as you sort
of get the vehicles in off the main uh
access roads and then part probably why
the gates are unlocked so they don't so
the back end of the Trap isn't causing
congestion so it's setting the site a
bit it's not a visual harm
um but the gates that I think we're
talking about are up here somewhere and
another one about there I think yeah
okay any more no questions against
cancer constable
hi am I right in thinking that the car
parking area will be permeable to allow
for drainage
um in a commercial site or not
short answer no if I explain chairman um
I think they're using McAdam for at
least the service roads I think I saw
somewhere unfortunately I didn't pen
this report so I haven't read every
every word of the support and statements
but I think they're using block Paving
to at least delineate the car park or
provide that
unlike a domestic residence
when you put the
um
surfacing in a in a domestic front
garden to a house the government has
been worried about flash flooding from
the runoff from all the parking areas
straight into the drains and somebody
down sound Downstream gets it yeah so
they they've introduced permitted
development rights in other words you
don't need planning permission if you do
it the way they say
whereby if you introduce a permeable
surface
or you have some kind of drain that
captures the water and takes it away to
a flower bed or somewhere then you don't
need plant permission and then if you
say no I don't want to do that I want
tarmac you know I like tarmac or
something and it doesn't dry and then
you need planning permission and
actually then what we do is we put a
condition on that it drains yeah so it
gets it one way or the other yeah when
the developers are doing sites like
these
they actually need to capture the rain
water through a surface so porous
doesn't always work unless it's
underneath it it's got some kind of
membrane or something that channels it
through because they run it through
interceptors and those interceptors
cleanse the water before it discharges
into the streams and rivers and things
so if you're going to trap that water
and filter it you really want an
impermeable surface to to angle away
from the carriageway capture it in some
kind of some somewhere haven't been
filtered and then through the flood risk
techniques
release it into the drainage Network in
a managed way now on the big sites
instead of having
they have a it's like a snail shell like
a Vortex so it comes in like this
awkward Helter Skelter like funnel
captures all the water and discharges it
through a small orifice that in no way
can release any more water than the 1.6
liters a second or whatever the
calculation has been and that's why you
have all these
swells and things in these areas
the hold it back in the system or you
have it in crates and tanks under the
car park so you're holding it all back
the storm abides and then probably if
it's a really bad one over the next 24
48 Hours the rain water haven't been
filtered because it's not perfect he's
he's trickling away into the stream and
avoiding flooding that's right yeah
sorry my needs to be part of the suds
report which we wait it is but I'm not
I'm not a drainage engineer but that's
the concept yeah I understand so I would
be tempted to worry if I saw a big car
park like that porous because it'll
pushed straight into the system whereas
if you've got it captured you can filter
it and clean it and you can control it
thank you but on a domestic residence
the government has said we want you to
do porous because they can't get you to
put in all that elaborate things so they
say if you put in a porous on a small
surface incremented up all up the street
you get less fuddy that's their Theory
so the short answer is this will be
incorporated in the suds report which
we've still got to look which
yes but I I don't I wouldn't expect it
was a point I wanted to make that would
be porous there's a reason hopefully
members in our clearing World wouldn't
expect actually they explained it very
clearly thank you very very clearly
this one
Council Ahoy
yeah thank you and chairman
just a couple of
queries and clarification really
the first one is on car parking sizes
I'm aware that
they're they're 2.5 by 5
minimum size they have said
where is he
um
which is to be used in exceptional
circumstances
um
I understand other sites on the larger
site have been approved with those
minimum sizes
in paragraph 3.56 we've got the wording
the the council has consistently
accepted the lowered parking Bay
dimensions of 2.5 by 5 meters
um
I just want clarification that you're
not holding this Hostage to the Future
that may be on this site
by the larger site but I don't think as
a council we generally do that I mean
this I know that I always argue against
it so I'm sure officers will remember
and I'm sure that we
do try to have our preferred size so I
just want some clarification there that
that wording just relates to this
site and the larger site rather than
Roger District as a whole
because I don't want people picking up
on this and saying that we've agreed
that that's generally accepted okay um
second point the second point is on
something we don't really come across
very often which is vain Park in Bays
there are no van parking Bays on this
site I accept Vans May well be using the
service yard
but
I would expect them to use General
parking as well at times and we've got
no van spaces on this site that I see
and potentially no others not on the
sites within the larger site either and
I I want clarification on why van spaces
which I think are 7.5 by 3.5 haven't
been used I'm I know if you look at the
parking standards it doesn't actually
mention van parking sizes but found
parking sizes are mentioned in the same
standard so I'd like to understand why
we can't ask for then size parking
spaces on a B2 or a B8 site Mike why
they've not been included thank you
chairman um the reason they're not
included dealing with the van sizes
first
um the site is self-managed members are
right that there's a service road area
but I think that's primarily for the
bigger hgvs and stuff might be
forklifted from from part to part on the
on the air at the back but when you've
got an operator like you've got IP code
they self manage we're not dealing with
like a council car park or something
where loads of different people with
their own priorities will all compete if
perhaps they're having a lot of Van
deliveries they'll probably put a
message out to staff you know don't park
in this area for the next six hours or
something like that so they they manage
it
it's on private land of course so
um there's not a critical need to make
van provision they would it's a large
site with lots of car parking the
expectation would be that they would
manage it themselves on the
justification
um unfortunately it can be district-wide
the offices and the highways advisors at
County have to come to a view now on
this development generally on the
outline we've accepted the minimum base
size of 2.5 by 2 point Sorry 2.5 by 5
which is why we haven't taken issue with
it on on this one it's lower than your
preferred by a 5.5 by 2.9 wide but
it could be that on another estate
elsewhere that uh the developers insist
to gain on providing the minimum which
is a national size the 2.5 by 5 is
is Nationwide
so although we've got a county standard
where that's anticipated to be preferred
and there's good reason for that larger
Vehicles opening of doors and things
um I actually participated in the fight
on this standard on the KFC which
started this problem the KFC that's over
the road up on the toomey's site and the
inspector
awarded costs against us
although we was pursuing the new
standard we had recently adopted been
all through examination county-backed
standard
the inspector felt because KFC could
demonstrate they build
um drive-throughs and restaurants all
over the country
that he felt that the larger standard
was unnecessary so he not only didn't
accept our argument but he clobbered us
with costs as well saying we couldn't
defend our case now that's undermined
our position in a number of cases where
we've tried to fight for the larger
schemes I think on the residential
schemes be more successful because the
the kind of vehicle ownership can be
more varied with families but on some of
the commercial sites I think we've
accepted
and as we have on this development as a
whole I'm talking about the whole park
we've accepted the minimum standard
which as I say is a National Standard
Essex has gone further for good reasons
asking for the larger one but we've not
um we've not not
resisted that as officers on this on on
this on this development and
I can't promise that you won't see
developments in the future where we will
be saying that the minimum is also
accepted we deal with it on on Merit on
a case-by-case basis but I'm not going
to give you that promise because I don't
think we're going to be able to come so
thank you Mike that's very cool about
that yeah
I think that clarifies my point that we
don't consistently across the district
on all applications except the lowered
parking standard thing
on this site we do but the officers
they are the preferred standard for
instance that's a residential one I've
just really worried about wording I've
been caught out with wording in the past
on applications causing problems and I
don't want it to be used in future
applications
sure which your officers always ask for
the larger parking standard but
doesn't help me in undermined by the
inspector in a simple way chair we we
shoot High when we when we meet these
people in pre-application Etc we point
out that there's a better preferred
standard
and we hope to persuade them to to put
that standard in
but if they choose not to we have to
think do we recommend to you to refuse
it that the car parking spaces are
inadequate
when the standard itself says there's
two choices
yeah
and then when you think that it's a
national standard as I've explained
which is like the fallback
then it sometimes undermines our our
position so you will see some sites
probably come through where the
developer is quite happy to provide the
preferred standard
in this case the applicant has felt that
the the minimum standard is good enough
and we've not really been able to mount
a case to say to you you shouldn't
accept it okay thank you sorry just very
quickly thank you I'm sorry to back on
about it I'm very happy with that that's
the answer I want but can we in future
make sure we don't say we consistently
accept lowered parking Stones because we
don't consistently it's wrong the world
is wrong and the site we have but not
generally
okay
nice it's okay
um any more questions
looks like with questions ourselves out
okay
all right then so we have a
recommendation to approve the
application subject to conditions 1
through 214 set out on page 7.1 and 7.6
and also
do you want to say something
yeah I was about to come to that yeah
and the
and also to have the recommendation that
the members dedicate the application to
the council's director of place
to determine on the basis of the office
of recommendation and taking into
account the reply to consultation when
we see from the lead local flood
Authority
so members can we have a show of hand oh
cancer Stanley
just one point uh chairman we would be
notified on the suds outcome of this
development
I do hope so
we we I'd say we can try I'll make a
note of it the problem is it's not
normally a procedural thing sometimes
you could end up email me did you ever
get a reply oh yes we did I'll do my
best to to let you be aware of it
um the best way is to go on to the
um the website of other way so let's see
if it's been built
thank you chair um I would quite like to
know when this decision is being issued
given it's being issued in my name so
I'll I'm happy to take that action on
councilor Stanley just to find out when
we've issued the decision and let the
development committee know that that's
happened thank you it's only for the
fact that we have got a very large
development yes and obviously we would
like to know the what goes on with the
suds with their actions and what they've
come up with and and we can use that in
the development committee for next
development whichever happens on that
site that's all I'm asking excellent
thank you very much right members can we
have a show of hands
to support this application please
looks like it's unanimous
thank you very much
I think that's that's it I think the
community meeting closes at 8 14.
thank you very much I wish everybody a
happy Christmas and a very merry New
Year